this is a blockbuster folks another one
in the continuing saga of increasingly
clear collusion between Donald Trump and
Russia up until now we've learned quite
a bit about back-channel communication
between WikiLeaks and Russia through
go-betweens right so there was this
Julian Assange interview where he said
our source for the leaked whatever was
not an official from Russia and later it
was revealed that that may well have
been true
by the word by but by the letter of it
but not in spirit because there were
middle people identified that were go
between between Russia and WikiLeaks it
has now gone further Roger stone
confidant to Donald Trump former adviser
during the campaign Roger stone admitted
on Saturday night late at night as often
as when news breaks involving the Trump
administration that he had a
back-channel to WikiLeaks founder Julian
Assange during the campaign very soon
after tweeting this he started
scrambling to delete the evidence from
the internet and deleted the tweets
although we have it we have it because
of something called print screen' the
ability to take screenshots where there
was a tweet from user r-va wonk saying
in March of 2017 Roger stone denies
contact with Assange in October of 2016
Stone says I do have back-channel
communication with Assange and Roger
stone responded to that you stupid
stupid [ __ ] never denied perfectly
legal back-channel - Assange who indeed
had the goods on crooked Hillary again
stone later deleting the tweet along
with a number of other offensive tweets
including posts where he was calling
different women fat and stupid this is
not that different from what stone
admitted back in October but it does
imply much more direct contact with
Julian Assange in October stone admitted
that he had a back channel to Assange
through a mutual friend of Assange and
stone now this seems to be an admission
of seemingly more direct contact
something which he clearly thought
better of after admitting it on Twitter
and attempted to scrub it but again
people
take screenshots so we have it this does
contradict an October of 2016 tweet from
WikiLeaks which stone was also
contradicting back then right WikiLeaks
tweeting back on October 13th WikiLeaks
has never communicated with Roger stone
as we have previously repeatedly stated
so again we may be in the world of
technicalities it could be that
WikiLeaks as an entity is different than
Assange as an individual and while
Assange had back-channel communication
with stone WikiLeaks as an entity did
not it could be that WikiLeaks didn't
know that Assange was having contact
with Roger stone it could be that the
contact took place after October 13th of
2016 it could also be that that Roger
stone is two straight up lying but what
we know is that this all stinks because
some combination of the following
appeared to be true the Russian
government was involved in hacks that
took place
the Trump campaign was in touch with the
Russian government WikiLeaks was a
clearinghouse for hack data some of
which is believed to have come from
Russia Trump's campaign had contact to
WikiLeaks possibly at minimum through
Roger stone and of course one Trump
cabinet member has also resigned already
for lying about contacts with Russia
Jeff Sessions has been caught lying
about contacts with Russia Paul Manafort
the former campaign manager resigned
again possibly because of illegal
contacts having to do with Russia it
doesn't look good does it it ratings the
list goes on and on doesn't it I mean
Roger stone has a terrible reputation I
mean he's often considered a hack for
the Republican Party he got off sup lies
and conspiracy theories so I don't know
if I'm really inclined to believe him if
he is the missing link here I think he
just couldn't control himself he had to
tell everyone about it but either way
it's not a good outcome it's not good
and the fact that he then deleted the
tweet is also not good none of it is
good nothing is supporting is the
defense of hey nothing weird went on
here today's program made possible in
part by zip recruiter if you're hiring
you've probably figured out if you just
post your job in one place you may not
get the quality candidates that you want
if you want to find the best candidates
you need to be posting to all of the top
job sites and you can with zip recruiter
which also already has nine million
resumes you can search through in their
database you can also add other people
to your account to really create the
most efficient situation to find the
best hire post your job with one-click
to over 200 job sites as well as social
media networks like Facebook and Twitter
with one click zip recruiter is sort of
like a search engine for finding and
posting jobs you also with their system
to quickly screen rate and hire
candidates you don't need to juggle
emails and calls to your office it's all
managed within the zip recruiter system
and if you have issues
zip recruiter has friendly and actual
human support staff ready to help you
you can find out today why zip recruiter
has been used by over a million
businesses zip recruiters website shows
trending career fields cities and
searches as well try it for free my
listeners and viewers can post jobs on
zip recruiter for free by going to zip
recruiter comm slash free trial that is
zip recruiter com forward slash free
trial